let's first look at the bolded demand in
this letter which says we call on all AI
labs to immediately pause for at least
six months the training of AI systems
more powerful than gpt4 so Jan could you
make the case for why this kind of pause
is necessary
in some ways the gold with the metal
with the letter was like more like a
Meta Gold less about it was less about
the poles much less about the six months
post the letter said uh at least six
months pause but it was basically
the goal was to create
common knowledge in a way that like
people have something to point to and
say that look we are concerned and we
see that other people are also concerned
let's do something about it the letter
was like very very explicit that this is
not about posing daily research okay it
was very particular that this is about
posing the large KLA experiments now now
are
uh kind of reaching hundreds of millions
of dollars they are experiments that are
sort of like I call them summoning of AI
because they are something like 200
lines of code and then like enormous
amount of data and they are unsupervised
the thing will be run for months without
humans checking what's happening and
then they stopped then they do the
checkpoint as they called and then they
see what this thing is capable and then
they can resume or or stop uh now the
problem is that
with with this experiments uh they are
producing uncontrollable Minds so I
think
one reason for some kind of pause or
some kind of timeout is that that's
informed the planet that their lives are
being risked now by the Insiders the
Insiders agree that like I have not met
with anyone right now in this lab so
says that sure the risk is less than one
percent of blowing up the planet
so it's important that people know that
the lies are being risked by this very
particular experiments this is can be
seen as a political trial balloon that's
often done in many contexts you raise a
flag and you see your salutes basically
what they're trying to do here is to get
more people to perceive that more of us
are okay with
something like regulating this because
of particular concerns they have so you
know my issues would be is this the sort
of thing now that's worth doing that
level of coordination or regulation uh
that would be the key question that is
this is a good thing to do if in fact we
are near the time when it would be a
good idea to coordinate in such a way
and that this would be a good first step
in that direction but if you think this
is too early
and we might go too far too fast then
this would be a bad idea
what are the conditions that you would
want to see met before you take your
finger off that pause button in terms of
training these large language models
that are at the level of GPT 4 or above
there should be an affirmative
cases made by people who are or
companies who are doing those
experiments that these will be safe how
did to the boss is very simple you just
like have US government to say that like
no such
big training runs until there there is
some external auditing and some
constraints in place by external
auditing are you saying that someone
from the federal government should come
in and you know the federal government
needs to establish some sort of
guidelines and an agency to go in and
make sure they're meeting these
guidelines so this is actually like a
point that I don't know if I have to say
that like I am kind of less informed and
and less knowledgeable about like what
is kind of
uh
the most effective Ankara most targeted
intervention there I would like kind of
the companies themselves together with
some external
non-biased uh
stakeholders to work out what these
constraints should be what seems to me
the main issue we should be discussing
here is how plausible is it that if they
let GPT 5 do training in the Untamed
mode then there's a one percent chance
of destroying the world in that training
run because that just seems crazy high
these things you know they just take
input and they give you output until you
hook them up as an agent in the world
that can do things they can't do things
and the usual feel people worried about
it somehow this thing will be so smart
that it will then figure out how to
improve itself but it doesn't have the
ability to improve itself unless you
give it those Powers so the question is
why should we be worried that the next
training run will destroy the world why
not just talk about where this whole
thing could go and how we want to worry
about that and I'm happy like I said I
have some compromise policy
recommendations for how we should you
know in a mild way try to deal with some
of the bigger long-term problems but I I
just can't buy this short term hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our live stream with Robin Hansen and
Jan talin about artificial intelligence
existential risk and the dangers of
preemptive regulation you can watch our
full conversation right here or another
excerpt right here